oggi facciamo a un gioco che ti piace un
sacco
fammi sentire come sia entusiasta di
giocare rocket league league
se devo andare
noi giochiamo cerchiamo è contento che
registriamo rocket league
bene io non costringo i miei amici a
fare video dai che mi servono le views
veloce e forte art on
milano rocket league veloce si giocano
che clima ci spacchiamo il fatto che tu
sei scarso roque trick non è vero non
credi in te stesso nel cuore delle
macchine macchine secoli xi allora
siccome sei giocare molto bene io faccio
una competitiva non vado dai competitiva
da allora a oggi si gioca serie oggi ci
qualifichiamo per i tornei mondiali mero
pietro mi piace che in voglio sempre i
miei amici a giocare alle cose
vai vai parti vai pietro vai pietro più
veloce sei lento come una scarpa morta
devi colpire la palla pietà dai dai dai
bravo ancora ancora così vai vai vai vai
butta in mezzo
bravo questo è il mio uomo bar ancora
ancora ancora toccato ma ciò io faccio
no vai a parare vai a parlare pietro
arrivo mamma quanto scarsi quanto può
essere scarsa una persona
allora vediamo se riusciamo a fare una
roba decente si passò motivo di segnare
dai mezzo non ci arriva e mi hanno
spinto in porta aspetta aspetta mi
riporta con comodo file agli ormai tocca
tocca la bravo in mezzo e mezzo tocca
ancora in mezzo di così non ci arrivo
non ce la faccio quando uccidono mette
in mezzo io sì
[Musica]
non si segna mai no non potevo farci
niente
va beh questa la contiamo
allora questi qua erano forti con questa
va sicuramente vista
abbandoniamo volta per abbandonare per
abbandonare abbandona tutto stiamo
giocando contro quattro tacche e due
tacche maledizione dai pietro falsa
facciamo cioè detto gol impegnati fammi
vedere che ci sei
ora di che colti faccio quali kakà tira
tuti ratu tirate con dove sei o vai è
tutta per te ne devi solo buttarla davis
ha invece ad altre due segno io 1 ora
per un gol basta stavo bravo top
bravissimo gol vedi medi così cattivo ti
voglio cattivo cattivo pietro non hai
fatto niente
lia intimoriti guardali come l'hai
mancata e laurent detto aula mancata per
far tirare lui in realtà 6 scarsa ma
loro non lo sanno cosa vuol dire una
fermo massei e tienilo fermo almeno qua
uno fair vediamo è tutto fermo vediamo
gli auguri tenuto fermo non ti è venuto
in mente che poteva accelerare da un
momento all'altro per bontà è passato
per l'anticamera del cervello come ti
sfotte guarda queste bella mé l'appoggio
da solo bahrami faccio gli auto assis
bravo piero va bene va bene dai fermata
che sta andando in porta bravo questo
così ti voglio così non è saper giocare
mica essere in grado di usare un
controller controllo un joystick giuste
da joystiq città sta giocando con la
tastiera si tu stai giocando col stai
giocando che mi dico la tastiera e del
joystick tu stai usando una tastiera per
giocare a rocchetto ma che problemi hai
usa un joystick ma si gioca con joystick
e ovvio che non sai ma se ciò conclude
la tastiera sembra un mongoloide ma sei
scemo sembra un mondo poetico ma era una
cosa aspetta che parte round
metti il culo sulla sedia veloce che
quella vinciamo così se sono anni che
non riusciamo a capire perché si è così
scarso e tenerci adesso che giochi con
con la tastiera ma non è normale giocare
come giocare a calcio con con la lingua
la tastiera non puoi giocare adesso
gioco è ingiocabile
io non sono anche che tasti premere
guarda se la prendi un controller
maledizione di conquistare la palla
dentro
ecco la madonna che gol ha fatto sto
tizio che gol ha fatto lui non la usa
della tastiera
c'è qualche gol ha fatto sto tizio dimmi
solo te cioè non so sei capi non so se
ha fatto di culo cosa dai da in uno
turbo devi farti devo fare io cosa tocca
tocca le basta tocca la attentato
previsto joystick per cortesia veloce
prendi la prendi sicuri dove la veloce
gioco da solo e tanto gioco meglio è
l'avevo detto io che da solo giocavo
meglio senza pietà 1 contro due gol
nostro gioco con pietro no vabbè in
tutto questo pietro non c'è perché da
solo ovviamente è un valore aggiunto
adesso pietro dovrebbe partire ma non
parte perché non c'è bene la maledizione
eccomi eccoti ti dico solo che non è
finita 5 3 ma ho segnato 5 4
vai vai maledizione ma cosa fai
ma perché non proprio davanti di
collegare tutto il controller vai fammi
vedere questo controller fare qualcosa
però ce l'ho ce l'ho
non ce l'hai pietro devi prendere la
palla non l'aria la palla in porta
maledizione non l'aria la palla la palla
colpisce la palla l'ho poi la madonna la
palla così importa tira libertà io sono
una persona di birra io te lo giuro
nella vita non ho mai avuto così tante
delusioni da una persona questo ti
chiedo per natale non mi devi fare
regalo non lo voglio per favore fai un
gol ma litio gol p è un gol diviso ma se
importa la palla e qua
bravo la porta avversaria ma dovevo
tirare proviamoci
voi come vi sono saltati bene ma tira
pietro da solo
questo è il mio uomo
questo nuovo guardali higuain può
accompagnare solo bravo tela stava
imparando da sola ma facciamo finta di
non averlo viene così così ti voglio
maledizione così si gioca con un altro
ma ecco adesso non tiriamo la corda
potremmo anche forse vincerla questa
partita si sa mai cosa ho preso cosa per
i sogni son parando l'imparabile vai vai
dietro questa nostra alla caritas tirava
e butta su no così piedi così si gioca
così pietro si gioca così carico così
paesi tira pietro tiro pietro due gol ma
mi vuoi fare impazzire oggi ma tu sei
scemo ma è un controller d'oro quello
bravo così magari madonna mi ferì oggi
mi sta regalando un sogno che non voglio
regali non voglio regalo di natale basta
è meglio che avere una [ __ ] di fianco
bravo ma ancora pietro voglio il 4 ma
l'ho fatto io chi se ne frega l'ho fatto
io ho segnate vista frase che non ha
sentirete dire molto spesso da pietro
adesso l'ultima che conferma che sei
diventato bravo va bene va bene
siamo contro l'inghilterra perché taglia
inghilterra ci sei vai
facciamogli vedere alla regina dice
facciamo capire alla reggina che le
puzza la novaco si carica
niente vai su palo sub ato non è vero
non segno nonno non assegnato
vai vai verso il muro
vi prego non può averne play non voglio
parlare non lo guarderò io cosa stai
facendo lì vai sul volo che cammina sul
muro ma vai vai vai sulla palla va sulla
palla
bravo vai in mezzo ma in mezzo sta in
mezzo solo in mezzo sono in mezzo sono
in mezzo e due case la pa non persa 0 2
abbiamo tre minuti possiamo farcela è se
ci mettiamo un impegno so che ce la puoi
fare pietro fai vedere che ci sei fai
vedere che sai giocare maledizione che
non è vero che non sai giocare palla al
centro
proprio ok no
no niente anticipato nella lettera entra
ma in mezzo ci sono ci sono io c'ero una
volta ho visto comunque vai su vai su
rai che recuperiamo dai 12 lascia la 22
non entrata rientrata maledizione il
mondo mi odia no no no no vai su pietro
tira questa palla mette dentro da due e
adesso vogliamo anche tra due prime
della sca televisivi secondi ci sei mai
che trovavano su fitta vai vai vai
carica la carica la piano chiaro
mamma mia che sudata va bene ragazzi
oggi abbiamo fatto giocare pietro e
abbiamo vinto ben due partite con pietro
siamo orgogliosi dei tuoi 10 punti
bravissimo abbiamo un distacco di punti
che è veramente di poco però come
possiamo vedere abbiamo fatto lo stesso
numero di gol
lo stesso numero di as lo stesso numero
di di parate ti tiri beh primer ai meno
pigri di me e meno pigri ma è in meno
big bravissimo grande pietro spero che
la gente vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
ringrazio pietro per la sua maestria che
ci ha mostrato oggi a tutti quanti
sprechi non sia piaciuto così tanto mi
piace anche la risorsa comitato nella
descrizione tanto ci siete vi ci vediamo
ad una prossima vittoria vero pietro si
beh ragazzi
[Musica]